to politics now in the impeachment
inquiry sources are telling CBS News
President Trump is likely to reject the
Democrats offer to appear when the House
Judiciary Committee starts hearings next
week and new reports say the president's
personal attorney Rudy Giuliani
discussed lucrative business deals with
Ukrainian officials while he was working
with them to investigate former Vice
President Joe Biden and his son hunter
we Jiujiang is traveling with the
president in Florida he is celebrating
Thanksgiving it is more lago resort we
good morning good morning David and good
morning to everybody you know Rudy
Giuliani's pursuits in Ukraine and how
much of them unquoted with the
president's knowledge are central to the
house impeachment inquiry into President
Trump and many witnesses have already
testified under Congress that it was
Giuliani who was leading the
administration's campaign to pressure
Ukraine to announce investigations into
the president's political rivals Rudy
Giuliani has denied that he tried to
rake in hundreds of thousands of dollars
from private business deals with
ukrainian officials I have no business
interest in your brain but he's
acknowledging that he did consider
working for one company in a statement
Wednesday his lawyer said bottom line is
he did not seek any business and turn
down the business that sought him
Giuliani's conversations with ukrainian
officials came while he was pursuing
damaging information about the Biden's
in recent days president Trump has
defended Giuliani's role in looking into
Ukrainian corruption Rudi is a great
crime fighter corruption fighter while
also claiming he did not send Giuliani
to Ukraine director but he he is a is a
warrior Rudy's a warrior Rudy went he
possibly saw some EU Ambassador Gordon
summoned is one of several witnesses in
the impeachment inquiry to describe
Giuliani as the mastermind of pressuring
Ukraine to investigate the Biden's I
followed the directions of the president
we worked with mr. Giuliani because the
president directed us to do so the White
House is also responding to a report
that President Trump found out about the
whistle blowers complaint in late
August before he released US military
aid to Ukraine a source close to the
president says that report shows that
the aides release was not connected to
the whistleblower complaint because he
waited at least 11 days Democrats say it
shows the opposite a lot of scrambling
went on after the fact to try to cover
their tracks
including the ultimate resumption of aid
itself so far we have not seen President
Trump during his break down here in
Florida but he does have one public item
on his schedule today a teleconference
with members of the military last year
the same event turned into a
freewheeling news conference so Michelle
you never know he might just chime in on
Giuliani impeachment and whatever else
he feels like talking about this is true
you never know we just thank you